what was the show that you were in I was
in a play called One Man Two Guvnors
that was the play where you brought down
or Trump up that's right right yeah yeah
usually I bring people up from the yard
every night we would bring people up on
stage and I would get them to move
something for me on stage there's like a
big trunk so the night that you brought
it to New York
we heard that Trump was in and almost
every night in that play there was
someone incredible in the audience but
you can't bring their puppet them up on
stage it's disrespectful you can't bring
up and win Wilder you Tom Hanks you
can't it's the you absolutely stirs the
no no well I know I be terribly
embarrassed
exactly and I'd be embarrassed to do
that to such a person however Donald and
I said to ally I was like Donald Trump
is the only person beloved we can bring
on stage I said because half the
audience don't really like him anyway
right so we either win with everybody or
we win with half the audience and listen
before he ran wave right before this in
2012 okay so I said if it's not going
great I'm gonna bring him up and we were
like that's it okay they'll be fine
amazing night yeah and then it was one
of those days of biblical reign for an
hour in New York in the summer the
heavens just opened which always makes
for a bad show because people are so
hang on their knees are wet I don't want
to be here and want to be snuggled up at
home anyway it's not it's not a great
audience and this is now show 425 and I
think [ __ ] it I'm just like I know where
he was about halfway back on the aisle
is she with Melania yeah and I grabbed
his arm yeah and I said you're coming
with me
he laughs no no he laughed yeah and he
came up and the audience goes wild and I
started saying I need you to move this
this is a thing called manual labor
you'll have never done this before no
yeah and I saw it and I moved him around
and I fired him and all things like this
and it was fun but here's the thing I
remember most about it when the people
would go off I'd get them to move this
trunk and take it into the wings out of
this door and then our stage manager
would stand with the people and he and
they'd often be a bit shell-shocked that
they were just on stage and he'd say
look you did great it was fantastic
wait here James is going to call you
back you'll walk across the stage and
back to your seat you did
right and I said to our stage rounder I
said what was he like in the wings and
[ __ ] you know I promise you this was the
response he went it was like he thought
he was the president of the United
States he went round shaking everybody's
hand in the wings but not in a genuine
way in a this is a big deal for you yeah
this is a big deal for you not to shake
my hand here but no one had ever done
that no and you can't argue with the
charisma of the man because to his
credit he goes up and people are
laughing by the end huge cheer because
what a great sport you know John the
sense he went over the audience that
night at the show yeah I think he did
what I know so I think the audience felt
like ah what a treat you know that they
saw something that they knew was real
that wasn't you know what I mean and and
also he wasn't running to be the
president United States he was the host
of The Apprentice